also today Daily Caller our own Sarah
Carter reporting to DOJ is refusing to
preserve work-related emails from the
former FBI director Jim Comey's private
account Wow wonder if they do that for
you or me now we reached out to the DOJ
for comment they declined here with more
reaction House Intelligence Committee
Chairman California Congressman Devin
Nunez frankly deserves the Medal of
Freedom for for really showing sadly the
biggest abuse of power corruption
scandal let's just get your general take
on everything and where we are and what
is important now Thank You Sean and
thanks for having me on again we're
really where we're at a lot of people
ask well what's left we still have
information that we need from the
Department of Justice however I will say
as of tonight we are getting closer and
closer to having the information that we
need tell us why one of the big issues
that they have provided they have
allowed all that all the issues that
were in our subpoena they have now been
able to review our investigators have
been able to review or they have been
delivered to the committee in one form
or fashion or another so let's put that
aside there's still more that has to be
done and we're of course months and
months late so where are we we talked
about this last week we have at least 20
pages of the FISA that was with the FISA
warrant that went after Carter page we
have about 20 pages that the House
Republicans have asked several months
ago for the president and in his office
to declassify we need that Declassified
senator Grassley secondly asked for the
Bruce for 302s Bruce or it's going to
become more and more important in this
investigation to do it explain a 302
which is an official report where they
altered so the FBI interviewed Bruce or
at least a dozen times and put together
reports so once they fired steel which
at that point they should have not been
meeting with him anymore but what they
had is they had Bruce or whose wife
Nelly or was working for fusion GPS was
going to meet and still get the
information for Christopher still as
they were trying to verify this
unverified dossier or the Clinton dirt
that was used to get the
as a warrant so that's number two number
three there is exculpatory evidence that
we had that we have seen of classified
documents that need to be declassified
these were not like SOPA Tory in nature
in what ways I'm going to press uux
culpa Tory in what way in that the
Carter page FISA when those the judges
should have been presented with the SATs
culpa Tory evidence that the FBI and DOJ
had so those are the three areas that we
have left in terms of what we need
Declassified isomers over on top of that
a tape and potentially Intel service
involvement in all of this is there any
truth to that well that I think gets to
the origins of the investigation which
we still are unclear on on whether or
not we know that the Australian diplomat
that was serving in London we were told
that it was five eyes intelligence that
was used to go after Papadopoulos what
we discovered in our investigation is
what there was no five eyes intelligence
and in fact down her story the
Australian diplomat doesn't even make
any sense so we're still trying to to
follow up on that but in the big picture
here
we need these documents Declassified it
that has to get done we just thought
there was a report secondly we have
about Paul Sperry that that might happen
I'm running out of time and I want to
get this in this is very important I
just played the tape of the April 2017
tape of your colleague shiftless shift
sorry Adam Schiff I won't add my
commentary to your comments and it
sounds like he's colluding with Russians
for dirt on Donald Trump and wasn't the
phony dossier that Hillary and the DNC
paid for wasn't that full of Russian
lies too and it wasn't used to
misinformed the American people and get
a FISA warrant as your memo pointed out
and the Grassley grand mountain all
pointed out the bulk of information for
the dice dossier for the FISA yeah well
look if it would have been up to the
Democrats they were in on this from the
beginning
so was the media Shawn the media in 2016
had all this information too so they
know that this information was being
generated by the Clinton campaign you
had DOJ FBI all those cast of characters
that were
meeting regularly with Christopher
Steele yeah Bruce or the number for the
Department of Justice who I think is
going to become a more and more
important figure in this and a lot of
the investigators and reporters should
be looking closer at Bruce or appreciate
your time this is soon maybe this week
that's what rumors I'm hearing good to
see you sir